9 вересня Олександр Лукашенко вже вп'яте за цей рік поїхав до Володимира Путіна.
Офіційно заявлена тема переговорів у Москві - програма інтеграції двох країн.
При цьому, як запевняє Лукашенко, жодної мови про втрату суверенітету Білорусі не йде.
Однак в опозиції подібне зближення Москви і Мінська викликає велику тривогу.
Лукашенко - політичний та економічний банкрут.
Як це часто буває в ситуації, коли людина заплуталася з боргами, кредитори приходять за його майном.
Головний кредитор Лукашенка та його системи - це Росія. Це не секрет.
Відповідно, Путін починає підбиратися до нашої квартири і намагається її віджати.
Один із лідерів білоруських націоналістів Зенон Позняк, який з 1996 року живе в еміграції, також вважає, що - цитата:
"Мета Кремля досягнута - клієнт, тобто Лукашенко, в його лапах".
Він закликав Євросоюз відновити авіасполучення з Білоруссю, заморозити економічні санкції та почати переговори про припинення репресій.
Його позицію підтримують і деякі незалежні експерти.
Білоруська влада чітко розуміє, що тут і зараз їм загрожують із Заходу і тут і зараз вони можуть отримати допомогу з Росії.
А потім відбувається те, що неминуче відбувається: країна стає настільки слабкою, що не в змозі відстоювати свої національні інтереси,
поступово втрачає суверенітет. Не тому, що хтось інший поганий, а це такий закон природи.
Росія та Білорусь обговорюють політичну інтеграцію двох країн з 1999 року.
Переговори останніх років стосувалися 31-ї "дорожньої карти" з питань інтеграції в різних сферах економіки та управління.
На початку вересня Лукашенко повідомив, що їх затвердження може відбутися у жовтні-листопаді.
Але багато хто вважає, що Лукашенко не особливо прагне в обійми Кремля.
Як тільки він підпише всі ці "дорожні карти", він більше нікому не буде потрібен.
Росія отримає те, чого хоче, а сам він перестане бути реальним керівником країни, контролювати ситуацію буде Кремль.
Тому Лукашенко раціональний. Він розуміє, що ефект від санкцій буде значним.
Він буде прагнути уникнути того, щоб санкції діяли повністю або посилилися.
Днями Брюссель повідомив, що працює над п'ятим пакетом санкцій. Там дуже скептично налаштовані щодо перспективи діалогу з Лукашенком,
який, на думку польського аналітика Клисінскі, наближає Білорусь до тоталітаризму.
Полегшення санкцій можливе, але тільки як привід для серйозних переговорів про нові вибори в Білорусі.
Можливо, потрібна буде нова конференція за участю нових акторів. У тому числі й Росії, вона не повинна бути осторонь цього.
Євросоюз, безумовно, зацікавлений у збереженні незалежності Білорусі, але небезпека її втрати для ЄС тепер, здається, не така страшна,
як той режим, який встановився в країні після серпня 2020 року, вважає Каміль Клисінскі.